alors le 18 max en effet elle nous vient
de s'y sentent bien forte du corps à
corps d'un carry ce
type c'est un symbole phallique ouvre
toi tu es un homme symbole feignasses
thalys cote la carte a dit scott tu vois
ce que je veux dire là et voilà tu es
dans la cage aux folles la tient bien sa
biscotte bien ses rêves se casse encore
tu vas 1 et
meghan markle voyez à qui donc ça
remonte vraiment à très très loin
puisque cette affaire qui sort seulement
maintenant il faut que l'on remonte en
2005 pour tenter de la comprendre mais
pourquoi ces symboles rex qui dit en
effet salle qui se veut un vrai si c'est
un acteur pour l'instant est en pleine
promotion d'un film red rocket et ils
ont partagé la fiche il ya eu en 2005 il
y avait un petit système qui marche et
ça marchait devant la mairie pas marché
l'aptitude code non non comme tout ce
que tu ne gagnes mais on dirait que ça
se passait dans sa salle mais voix
furent pour le coup elle décroche un tel
rôle meghan markle dans cette petite
sommes dans cette petite série e ou le
nom de l'épisode s'appelle nine bolt
find it bag de mon éthique pas et dirt
ou d'accord et 1 se sont très bien
entendus c'est un beau couple à l'écran
d'accord jamais la passe et d'autres il
est beau lui lui
au moment où on faire bon alors au
moment du mexique en 2001 à toi ma villa
bleue mais vraiment ça à s'exciter sur
meghan markle en effet il le seul pour
ne pas le citer vient vers lui s'adresse
à lui et lui dit est-ce que vous
accepteriez contre 70 milles de l'art de
nous dire que vous avez eu une relation
que vous avez couché avec meghan markle
alors c'est pas une star à simone rich
il a d'ailleurs cela qui est intéressant
lorsqu'il était jeune tourner dans des
films pornos gays pour s'attaquer les
quelques années quelques
recherches n'ont pas été justes que la
semry comment
continuer l'émission on le sait
il dit je ne peux vraiment pas fait cela
à la famille royale il refuse l'histoire
a été en effet dévoilé par le guardian
on ne le dit pas non plus dernièrement
et voilà il balance la chose en quelque
sorte alors évidemment ce que l'on peut
se dire quand même et il a dit en effet
j'ai été heurté terriblement par les
méthodes des tabloïds
ils sont prêts à tout va vous parler
dans ce couple alors et mais en tout cas
qu'est-ce qu'il visait lui un peu
saimone l'ex machete kills est en promo
de son film dé comparer de son fils vous
voyez bien ça marche mathieu puisqu'on
est en soixante dix mille dollars
c'était très important à mon chéri mais
c'est l'oseille la file a refusé à
l'espace
qu'il a fait il a refusé et il en a
parlé à vous dire que c'était quelqu'un
de bien parce que ça les deux qu'il
avait une promis naturel c'est quelqu'un
de là mais tout cela pour vous dire que
y'a rien de très révélateur dans ce
qu'ils nous disent que c'est qui nous
apprend sur les tableaux mis dedans le
fond onana ces
dames et les singles parce que moi à
rabat pour 70 milles balle a alors
encaissé six buts parce que vous avez
conscience aux usa avec ou chansons en
angleterre qu'est ce qu'on est en train
de dire et je vois lui dit final il fait
des arguments je vais c'est du racisme
et on s'acharne entre megan gueule voilà
c est ce que c'est vraiment du racisme
dans les tabloïds pratique ces méthodes
là avec tout avec tout le monde donc je
ne pense pas vraiment que l'on puisse
qualifier cela de racisme alors le vide
on sait quoi machine de guerre alors
j'ai une question très intéressante que
je vais d'abord posé à ludivine pour
avoir une réponse qui ne l'est pas et
ensuite à vous
est-ce que je commande pour toi tout ce
qui se passe autour de megan c'est du
racisme pas tout mais yahia je pense qu
il n y en a une très grande qualité 2
voiler la face en dix ans mais pas du
tout on fait avec elle comme on a fait
avec diana avec elle malheureusement il
ya aussi le sceau du racisme parce que
ça dérange parce qu'on a pu mais si
alors je vais te dire quelque chose de
divine gp 5 doc en entier au vin megan
est adoré par le public anglais est
détesté par la monarchie britannique et
bien diana était adorée par le public
est détesté par la monarchie à ce que je
sache que j'ai manqué quelque chose
diana n'était pas noir absolu ont mis le
qatar était aussi de réfléchir à
l'envers est calme et 2
ces deux chars elles mégane a divorcé de
l'angleterre ça c'est vraiment différent
le plan à l'accuser de racisme quand on
sait que est-ce que tu t'imagines que
cette fille qui n'a absolument pas une
seule goutte de sang noble et conduite
sous les yeux du monde entier à l'hôtel
par le futur roi d'angleterre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'avenant
on a joué qui était considéré
la mercedes
n'est pas parce que
l'on avait su bien on n'aurait pas parlé
bertrand va pas me l'énervé va pas bonne
énervé
attention alors si je te permettent si
je peux me permettre
ludivine pour le coup toi tu fais le job
divinement parce que l air cette annonce
une ludivine n'est plus quelque sorte et
annaba pas la trempe pour le faire toi
je trouve je trouve vraiment qu étant
une femme de couleur tu le ferais
terrible tu penseras nous faut du divine
à la monarchie britannique quand même à
la riveraine cessation et tout ça coûte
la reine imposerait sa
perruque qui arriverait au tessin
dans mes dessins commun des cités avec
une gare au palace est vraiment ils en
ont deux soit tu sais ma petite chérie
fm rire je vais écrire pour toi d'accord
c'est vrai que je ne fais que me
remettre ta lettre tu as toutes ses
chances quoi il m'a vu elle l'a
t'imagines votre majesté à nouveau la
petite vieille oui
je la lis en urgence du majestic je vais
l'apprendre merci de rester légal odeurs
et de prendre ludivine rhétorique
et la première chose que tu commences à
faire tu parles up moite meghan markle
dans des termes trop gentil copé logis
d'accord le soit pas déjà un peu de tout
bon déjà tu parle anglais bien sûr alors
là vas-y
vas-y tu dis comme à moi de l'argent
money money money ne dis moi ce que tu
viens de penser de la chronique
débattront des cartes en anglais si tu
es d'accord et
q3 mais zing d'azul robertson racing
also that you are you talking about
mégane bête à still love you
[Applaudissements]
répondre eh ben c'est pas ta part oui
mais